are joined now uh from westminster by
lord president of the privy council
jake cabrece mog a key figure in the
decision that was made yesterday to
suspend parliament so let's talk about
this
perogary if that's even a word i'm sure
you will know
um it's interesting isn't it your own
cabinet members are calling this move
undemocratic no they're not because
i think two things are being conflated
one is the routine beginning of a new
session set out the domestic agenda
which is what is happening
and the other is the suggestion that was
going around in
the leadership election uh for the
conservative party that you would
suspend parliament from july through
and beyond the 31st of october i was
saying at the time that that was absurd
nobody was no sensible person was in
favor of that in my view
that would have been constitutionally
improper but we have a new session of
parliament normally every 12 months
this session has already run well over
two years
we are not losing many days
parliamentary debate because it
coincides with the
uh conference recess so this is routine
it's actually quite boring but the arch
remainers who don't want us to leave the
european union
have started crying constitutional
crisis but actually they're crying wolf
okay this is interesting this is what
boris johnson said to
sophie ridge here on sky news in june he
said i don't want
nor do i expect to prerogue not
attracted to it
i don't think it will be necessary it's
interesting isn't it
the timing of this because let's be
straight here you're doing this to get
brexit done by the 31st of october
no that's not right because parliament
will come back in early october
and we'll have lots of time to debate
brexit
but crucial how much time we're
estimating four or five days
no the key here is that the european
council takes place on the 16th 17th
of october that will be when any
decision is made
on any agreement and then there will be
13 days after that
to debate and implement an agreement if
one is come to
so that's the key period when parliament
needs to be sitting and parliament will
be sitting
but it also crucially means we can have
a new queen's speech and we can get back
to talking about the nhs dealing with
crime improving
but that will lead to time won't it
because after the queen's speech
there'll be four or five days of debate
then that also eats up time
and you have to admit mps if they'd have
been allowed to continue
without this suspension of parliament
they would have voted to stay put
instead of disappear for party
conference season well
let me answer your two points
individually um the debate on the
queen's speech
has nominal um areas to debate day by
day
but actually you can speak on any matter
relating to the queen's speech so people
could spend the whole of those four to
five days
debating uh leaving the european union
and they could put down an amendment
to the queen's speech or to the humble
address uh
thanking the queen for her speech um
saying
things about the european union so that
is four or five days which can be
debated to brexit
in terms of the conference recess at my
first
and so far only outing at the dispatch
box i referred to the conference recess
and said i expected it would go ahead
and the opposition chief whip nodded in
agreement and that's all recorded in
hansard
so it had been agreed that the
conference recess would go ahead
as it always does parliament hasn't sat
in late september for 80 years
do you admit though that this has made
it harder for mps to stop
a no deal you won't admit it's the main
aim of this move but it may be a
convenient byproduct
i don't think it is actually i think
those who don't want to leave the
european union
um have to um screw their carriage to
the sticking point
that uh there are two ways for them to
stop us leaving the european union
one is to change the government and the
other is to change the law they don't
seem willing to do either of these two
things because
actually 17.4 million people voted to
leave and they don't
want to blow a raspberry at more than
half of the
electorate and that's why they cry
constitutional crisis
which is actually cover and code for
them trying to keep us in the european
union
against the law of the land and against
the referendum result
it's interesting then you're saying they
have two options either change the
government or change the law
let's talk about some extreme options
the government
could use to carry on and get brexit
through on the 31st of october
these have been talked about one of them
is that if mps do manage to pass
legislation to stop a no deal
boris johnson could simply ignore it
would he do that
you can't ignore legislation the law is
the law
um but the law has to be precise so i
don't know what law
you're proposing would be passed well it
may be that he
has to go back to brussels to seek an
extension for example
would he ignore that if that was the
option put to him we'd have to see how
the law is phrased the prime minister
will obey the law the prime minister
believes in
the rule of law our whole system is
based on the rule of law
and crucially what is happening now is
in line with the rule of law and the
oddity now is that this parliament has
gone
on so long and having this chance for
new queen speech is actually
really energizing because it means we
can get back uh to the issues that have
been ignored for the last three years so
we can
get back to improving the nhs to dealing
with knife crime and so on
legislation boris johnson will follow
that okay
if mps don't manage to change the law in
the four or five days
that they will be sitting there's a
prospect of a no-confidence vote
if it succeeded would boris johnson
resign or would he continue
well the question there is would
parliament have a majority for another
leader and who is putting his or herself
forward for that
um it seems to me that mr corbyn does
not command and has no prospect of
commanding
uh support of the majority of the house
of commons um so they'll have to look
for other figures
the constitutional norms are always
observed
it's interesting isn't it because you
say that you want to focus on the
domestic agenda that's what the
suspension is all about
but a lot of people are seeing this as a
bit of a ruse because parliament hasn't
passed any domestic
agenda in a year even more unlikely to
do so with just a majority of one
so again i go back to the point of being
straight this is to
subvert parliament and clear any
obstacles to leaving the eu on the 31st
of october people just want
you to be straight with them no you've
put it brilliantly absolutely superbly
thank you put the case for the
government
this session of parliament has stopped
passing any useful legislation it is an
adult parliament
it needed to be brought to an end so you
could have a new and fresh session of
parliament
that would be able to start with new
builds you can't bring in
complex new bills towards the end of a
session because there isn't time to get
them through all the stages
knowing how how more likely are you to
pass any of these domestic bills with a
majority of one
of the people preoccupied by brexit the
labour party who wants to improve the
health service i imagine the labour
party wants knife crime to come down the
labour party
i imagine wants to see people's standard
of living improved there are many many
things that parliament can do
where there is lots of support and
sometimes you get
a political shenanigans and people
pretending to impose oppose things that
they're in favor of
but that doesn't mean you can't get
important domestic legislation okay
suspending parliament for four to five
weeks i mean i look at
you know periods of years past in 2010
it was three days 2012
seven days 2016. it was five days this
is highly unusual it was deeply
selective if i may say so in 2014 it was
20 days uh in 1997 it was 19 days
in 2015 it was three days
first minister nicholas sturgeon says
the pm is acting like a tin pot dictator
you're setting a dangerous precedent
here aren't you look
i'm afraid nicholas sturgeon's default
position is fair
outrage if the prime minister said
christmas day was the 25th of december
nicolas sturgeon would be outraged and
shocked by that so i wouldn't worry too
much about what
the scottish leader has to say i think
the key point here is sitting days we
are not losing many sitting days we may
only lose
five sitting days which is completely
routine and in line with the figures
that you were giving
okay and just finally how confident are
you of a deal being reached
boris johnson originally when he went
into number 10 said it was a million to
one chance of not getting one
he said it was reasonable after the g7
meeting at the weekend which is
quite the scaling down what are the
chances of it as it stands today
well it takes two to tango and it will
be um up to the european union to decide
whether it wishes to have a reasonable
deal
or whether it's going to insist on
vassalage in which case we will leave
without a deal